this is a production of cornell
university
uh so today i'm going to be talking
about the malice venturi patha system
and how host adaptation and the
geographical isolation
leads to population differentiation and
the impact that it has on
post-resistance breeding in apples
so
the fungus venturi necklace is aspirin
asparagus
fungus
that's the causal organism of apple scab
it causes olive to green or olive green
to black lesions on the leaves
and these black cracked creams on apples
this is a very significant disease in
apples
producers have to undergo really
extensive management practices in order
to control it
because these cracks severely reduce the
fruit quality and can just completely
decimate produce yield
the spores have a very limited dispersal
area
but they do undergo a sexual phase in
their yearly life cycle
and frequent recombinations lead to high
variability within the fungus
so for management of apple scab
like i said it's a really significant
disease and primarily management focuses
on
proper organ sanitation so making sure
that
leaf litter is removed at the end of the
season uh because that is where the
sexual recombination occurs for the
fungus so proper removal of leaves and
destruction of that uh
inoculum is really important
careful fungicide application to make
sure you're not leading to fungicide
resistant populations and then also
developing resistant cultivars it's
really important
for stable long-term management
especially for organic growers who don't
necessarily have the same chemical tools
that conventional growers do
so
in apples
there are currently 18 identified
major genes
that are resistant to apple scab
we call these rbi
and
there's a gene for gene interaction
between these
malice rvi genes with
pathogen avr genes
these effective proteins trigger the
downstream immune response
and about 90 of scab-resistant cultivars
rely on a single gene rbi6
this is originally identified in malice
floribunda 821
this resistance has since been broken
uh it's been repeatedly identified in
europe uh but last year it was actually
identified here in new york as the first
case in north america
this is really a cost for concern
that rbi gene
is in a tight gene cluster on focus
group one
and another one of my projects is
looking at another
candidate host resistance gene from
honeycrisp that's also located in this
type gene cluster
between rbi 6 and rbi 17
so apple domestication originally
started in the tunisian mountains and
what's now kazakhstan uh
and
that's the center of origin for the
primary progenitor species for apples
malice versailles
malu subversii was brought along the
silk road trading route where it
hybridized with other apple species in
the area
primarily malice orientalis in the
caucasus area and malucildestrus in
europe
this hybridization was really important
for the
co-evolution of venturi necklace because
the
post-geographical movement
towards europe as well as the
hybridization with other local species
led to three really identifiable
populations of the eye
so there's the central asian mountain
population that's only found in the
chanshan origin of malus aversion
there's the central asian plains
population which can infect malice of
rci and malice domestica which are our
moderate domesticated apples
and then there's also an eu population
that only is identifiable
in europe and
uh these populations can overcome mouse
silvestris and mouse or mouse domestica
so these three populations are really
clearly identified well reported on
um but one of the things that we are
really interested in is looking to see
if the post differentiation and
geographic isolation
of north american isolates led to a new
unique population
so
we're looking at the geographical
isolation between europe and the united
states
as well as any host adaptation that
might have occurred with north american
isolates
so we started out with 164
isolates that we collected both
from ncbi they're probably available and
from our lab
we have
illumina short read sequences from them
we removed 41 of the isolates
either due to poor sample quality or
contamination determined by the mating
type locus analysis
and so we aligned these sequences
against the ncbi reference genome
we filtered out the alignment reads for
quality
and then we conducted snip calling with
the
gap k haplotype collar
so we ended up with a little over 19
million raw snips and we underwent snip
filtration over a couple of stages to
make sure that we weren't losing out
quality sniffs uh as we were going
through
these full productions
so we started off with just some very
basic
filter parameters to try and remove the
lowest quality sites
i brought us down to about 4.4 million
uh and then we wanted to look at
population level snips um to bring that
data set down to a workable
range so
that brought us down to 375 000
and then finally we did hard
heterozygosity filtering because venturi
is a haploid fungus
and so any heterozygous sites uh would
just be due to sequencing error
so principal component analysis appears
to show uh
our north american isolates starting to
form their own distinct subpopulation
you can clearly see other populations
identified that are due to both host uh
geographic adaptation and
uh
sorry geographic isolation and host
adaptation
uh you can see the european malice and
it's covered up by the zoom bar up there
and then the two other identified
populations the uh cam and cat
populations that's the
central asian plains central asian
mountains
as well as the population
that was obtained on malus orientalists
so pci
appears to show uh a population
developing
however
further bayesian analysis shows that
there's not enough statistical support
to show that these population or these
isolates have formed their own
true population yet uh what it likely
means is that there just hasn't been
enough time for that population to
develop um
apple domestication took a took place
over a range of thousands of years
but
these isolates only been in north
america for the last few hundred
so we really just haven't seen
these isolates form their own distinct
population yet
and also
it was the process of
both the host adaptation due to
hybridization and the geographical
movement that led to these distinct
categories so i think that also played a
role in why we haven't seen a true
population arise yet
but looking at just isolates that we
collected in geneva new york
up around agritech
we actually did identify three
subpopulations within a single orchard
and the key characteristic that defines
these subpopulations is the ability to
overcome that key resistance gene rbi6
so two of the populations have the
ability to overcome
um
but there are two very distinct
populations that have that
characteristic
so what that likely means is that either
two resistance overcoming events
happened in the same orchard
or an isolate that can overcome was
introduced later on
and this orchard did not have any kind
of
disease management
so that probably also
is very significant for allowing that
selection pressure to come out
so just kind of wrapping up
these north american ices haven't yet
formed a distinct population just due to
the limited time that they've had in
isolation from other
key populations
um
and this work in the future can help
identify those pathogen avr genes
which are really important for
identifying new populations of the
pathogen that can overcome
host resistance as breeders continue to
develop new resistant cultivars
and also identifying the snips that
occur in these effectors can also help
us try and understand how
uh the host uh adaptation of the
geographic isolation
actually led to these population
differentiation and how this might
happen again in the future
i'd like to thank the
con lab for their support um as well as
the other two members of my committee
sarah pat the bridge and lance kadel
davidson
i have a question yes um how long do you
think will isolation of new culture
verse take in like a time frame like how
long do you think it would take for a
u.s or north american population to form
or um like even to spread through the us
with like a time scale
not a hundred percent sure and part of
the reason why
that might not be the case is uh just
due to how
really isolates are able to move between
areas now just due to
global trade
so originally that limited sport
dispersal played a key role in why
the isils were able to slowly evolve
with the co-domestication process
but now isolates can travel between
europe and north america in a few hours
along with defective materials
so
rapidly being able to go back and forth
might mean that they might not ever uh
form their own unique population
can you
transfer the disease with if you bring
like an alpha apple fruit
is it an infected apple fruit from
europe to the us for example or does it
have to be meat material
um no you can bring
infected fruits as well but typically
affected fruit isn't transferred as
often
the blemishes that applescrap causes are
so devastating to the fruit price uh
then most farmers don't even bother
trying to harvest them they identify
with the field
thank you
yes
so do you have an enough understanding
of the
effectors and the translations to be
able to start structurally modeling it
you know at the level of protein-protein
interactions
uh not yet um
part of that is that uh venturi
effectors are still uh
a very
emerging uh area of study uh we just
received
uh
a set of candidate effector sequences
from uh carl mezarek in new zealand and
we have annotation data for uh these
snips in this reference genome so part
of what we're going to try and do next
is look at the
uh
the snips within these candidate
effector regions and look at the
predicted effects uh they have on the
protein
uh translation
uh and hopefully then we might have a
little bit better but not quite there
yet
so you do you think they affect the
range translation or the actual protein
structure
the protein structure
exactly it was kind of is you know where
we are now with you know proteins
predict their structure
yeah this whole question be able to dock
things you don't have to crystallize now
thank you
and that's applause for everyone who
spoke today
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu